and the grammy goes to
walmart
olivia
sour olivia rodrigo
olivia
officially made her grammy debut on
sunday and boy was it a big evening for
her yes the good for you singer kicked
off music's biggest night by hitting the
red carpet in style wearing a very
glamorous vivian westwood gown but
before the ceremony even began olivia
nabbed her first award winning best pop
solo performance for her breakout hit
driver's license during the grammy's
pre-show and during the live telecast
olivia first took to the stage to
perform that grammy-winning single i
guess you didn't need what you wrote in
that song about me
[Music]
i think you could say olivia's night was
definitely more sweet than sour as she
emotionally accepted the grammy for best
new artist this is my biggest dream come
true thank you so much
and the awards didn't stop there yeah so
olivia won her third grammy of the night
by taking home the award for best pop
vocal album for sauer and dedicated the
win to her parents i want to thank my
mom and my dad for being equally as
proud of me for winning a grammy as they
were when i learned how to do a back
walkover
this is for you guys and because of you
guys thank you